you've lived your whole life in an
orphanage that's hiding a deadly secret
what do you do when your world is
flipped upside down and you realize
you're destined to die there's no way
outside of this place and not a single
person can be trusted i'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the promised
neverland
these kids are about to get a brutal
surprise emma here is an innocent 11
year old girl while looking through this
gate her and two other kids begin to
wonder about what's outside the concrete
walls of their home the next day she
wakes up to a bunch of kids running
around a house these kids are all
orphans and none of them have ever seen
the outside world while messing about
she bumps into a friendly woman who they
call mom the kids gather together and
play a game but while playing emma and
norman here reach a short gated fence
according to mom passing the fence and
leaving the orphanage is off limits
until you turn 12 years old the kids
wonder about what's behind the gate but
they don't know that nothing is beyond
there other than certain death this
adorable little girl is the next lucky
candidate to leave the orphanage all the
kids say their goodbyes before mom takes
her way to the gates gathering in the
food hall they noticed that the little
girl left her bunny toy behind being the
nice children that they are these two
run after mom and the girl to give it
back by the time they reach them they
find the gates open and see a truck
looking in the back of the truck they
find the same little girl that just left
but there's only one difference she's
been brutally killed before they can
even process what just happened some
deadly looking monsters open the gates
nearby while emma and norman rush under
the truck they pluck the girl from the
truck and put her in some sort of
hibernation chamber being only six years
old she's regarded as average quality
but the monsters are expecting some
higher quality 11 and 12 year olds very
soon it turns out this orphanage is not
for charity at least not for the kids
listening in they realize their home is
actually an operation that raises the
kids until they're taken off and eaten
by these monsters which are referred to
as demons mom has been in on the whole
thing working with the demons to raise
and feed the children to them the two
kids escape back to the home but
accidentally leave the toy bunny under
the truck which is found by the demons
and her mom now knows someone's finally
seen her one second i'm living a
relatively normal life and playing with
my friends the next second i see a cute
little girl decimated by some
traumatizing creatures if i'm emma i
would honestly give it a day this
orphanage is the only thing i've ever
known and i'm only 11 years old once the
shock of seeing a six-year-old's
lifeless corpse has finally passed i
would get to planning obviously
something is seriously messed up in this
place and any adult i see can't be
trusted the only adult in this place
right now is mom and she's been tricking
us our whole lives we should have known
though as far as it goes no kid has ever
come back to say hello or thank you for
all the hard work mobs provided with
such a big orphanage i would be a little
suspicious already this also raises
another question how has no one ever
chased after one of the kids before this
orphanage seems to have been going on
for at least a decade and now we've just
discovered that our friends have been
shipped off to die if i was a kid i'd be
running after each and every one of my
friends to say goodbye how has no one
ever seen the insides of this gate
either way these two kids have just had
their lives turned upside down waking up
from a nightmare emma here has a
completely new view of the orphanage
emma and norman realize that all the
regular school-like activities like
exams and such decide who gets eaten
first but no matter how smart or dumb
you are after the age of 12 everyone is
sent off to death
from past experience they figure out
that every two months another kid is
sent off being the responsible kids that
they are they decide to make a plan to
save all the kids and escape the
orphanage first off we need to leave
this place but we can't take everyone
some of these kids have barely escaped
the womb and there are no condition to
be running around the outside world
according to early developmental
scientists children over the age of five
usually have nearly finished cranial
development and have some idea of how to
consciously make decisions so what i'm
doing is telling all the kids above and
around the age of seven and letting them
know about what i've just seen but we
have to pick our words carefully we're
dealing with kids and kids aren't too
good at keeping secrets if that happens
i'm for sure being sent off to demon
hell and to never come back seeing that
i've been here my whole life i should
know who i can and cannot trust i'm
telling those i trust about what i saw
and making sure they're not going to
tell anyone else but the kids under 7
aren't useless they can be used as bait
since moms prepare to do the most savage
things to kill us we'll be doing the
most savage things to escape looking at
the gap between the bars it looks just a
notch too small for our 11 year old
heads to fit through so that's where one
of the younger kids come into play to
make this as safe as possible we'll go
during the night when mom's asleep from
there we can use one of the kids to walk
around looking for a switch or something
to open the gates we seem to have about
25 kids judging by how big the food hall
is when the next kid is sentenced to
death i'm telling all the younger ones
and the older ones i trust to come with
me on a trip i would try my best to keep
the younger kids oblivious to what's
going on because i'm such a nice guy
when i reach the gate i'm instantly
ditching the younger kids taking my
friends and sprinting to the other side
we'll have 24 crazy children running
around which might be just enough of a
distraction for us to make it while it
seems like a suicide mission for the
younger kids and we don't know what's on
the other side of the gate it's better
than voluntarily getting ripped apart by
horrifying demons they run to the outer
edges of the orphanage and find a big
concrete wall mom reveals to the others
that she's holding a tracker that makes
sure none of the kids go missing while
they play meanwhile the two kids find a
massive wall on the edge of the
plantation and make plans to scale it
this quiet kid called rey finds them and
asks what they're up to the two
explained themselves by telling him what
they saw the night before he's shocked
but he believes them and agrees to team
up gathering in the food hall mom
introduced a new infant to the family
and a tall lady who's probably in on the
child killing business as well a
flashback of the two shows they're not
good friends but simply business
partners the tall lady is scheming to
overtake her and become her successor
this new infant is shown to have a
scratch near her ear showing where the
tracking devices are stored okay things
just got a lot more difficult but we now
know that we've been tracked this whole
time we don't know how it works but
considering it i can't imagine it's as
accurate as a smartphone gps considering
the fact that we've spent significant
time at the gates and was sitting under
the truck either mom's bluffing and
waiting for the perfect time to strike
or her device isn't as good as she
thinks i would bet that her watch works
similarly to a compass where she can
only tell the direction but doesn't have
pinpoint accurate location technology we
can use this to our advantage when
planning our escape especially knowing
that she doesn't know who is on the
tracker either human microchips are
pretty high-tech stuff so we have to
assume that whoever mom is she's not
working alone there must be some pretty
costly backing especially knowing that
since there's a constant supply of food
clothing and shelter to keep us safe
chips inside children especially infants
are currently unheard of so whatever
technology these guys could have could
be something super advanced i would be
inspecting every single little precious
kid to see what the frick nuts is going
on with these trackers and seeing if
there's any way i can manipulate them
into breaking it depending on how deep
the chip is and it doesn't look too deep
it may be possible to kill it with an
electrostatic charge what we need to do
is to cut a hole in a piece of rubber a
pvc pipe cut it on one end wear
something like running shoes and you
know what screw it just take a knife and
cut the ear off of the precious child
it's a lot faster i'm sure the kid won't
mind in order to train the children the
three hatch a plan to play tag which
works as a disguise while they increase
the kids fitness levels the tall lady
jumps in as well and tells the kids if
they can hide for 20 minutes without
getting captured they win she turns out
to be an expert athlete but rey and
norman managed to outrun her later that
night the main three kids have a talk
and realize that one of the kids might
be a mole sending information to mom
things just got a lot more complicated
the kids keep on training meanwhile
norman suggests that their leaving date
be in 10 days instead of 45 days to
trick mom later on the main three decide
they need to tell more of the kids about
their plans to have a better chance of
success glasses girl and the tall kid
are the next to be let in on the plan
but norman makes sure not to mention
anything about that kid dying earlier to
keep them from freaking out the search
for the mole continues with the kids
laying a trap by leaving a piece of rope
in two different places for mom to find
suspecting the new members norman tells
the two new recruits different places
where the rope is if the rope is gone on
the first floor the tall kid is the mole
but if it's gone on the second floor
glasses girl is the one the mole slips a
note under mom's door later on that
night finding that the note is gone rey
and norman dial it down to one person
the mole is rey rey lets it out that
he's the one sending mom the group's
information he confesses and lets norman
know that he's been working with mom for
a number of years to save himself from
being killed he says he'll continue to
help the kids as long as norman promises
not to save everyone he says it'll be
impossible for all the kids to make it
and all must be sacrificed to ensure the
success of the operation they both agree
to the conditions but make a promise to
not let emma know rey must be some sort
of super genius or norman must be a
freaking idiot he's fooled all of us for
the longest time and managed to trick us
even when we first told him about our
escape plan we know rey is about 12
years old which means he's been working
with mom since he was pretty much
capable of thought if i'm emma or norman
i'd be pretty doubtful of this guy now
we've all been microchipped and we don't
even know what's inside it mom could
have some sort of crazy technology that
lets her control her every move and
action he could be under mind control
right now for all we know we've seen
crazier things happen in the last few
days but since he's already in front of
us we should take some time to pick his
brain he seems like a really smart kid
and probably knows more than any other
child in this house the older five get
together and figure out there's a secret
room located in mom's room while most
think it's too dangerous the tall kid
here wants to find out what happened to
the girl who got taken away him and
glasses girl go off to see what secrets
lay in the hidden room the main three
find a few books by famous author these
books have hidden messages covered in
morse code that might show a way out of
the orphanage meanwhile tall boy and
glasses girl managed to get the key to
the secret room going inside they see
the toys of all the kids who were killed
while pretty disturbing they managed to
also find a communication device to the
orphanage headquarters okay this is a
gold mine of information i didn't know
before that there was a massive library
inside the house but i guess it makes
sense because we need to study it makes
me wonder though what exactly are we
studying about i would take my time and
look through more of these books books
are knowledge and knowledge is power i
would find some books related to science
or history that could help us escape
this place and also maybe a book on
survival maybe if i look hard enough i
can find something that might help us
escape the operation like how to make a
hang glider with this many books there's
bound to be a whole boatload of useful
information even taking some time for
personal enjoyment wouldn't be a bad
idea we've been under a lot of stress
considering we don't have any technology
books is the next best thing once we
leave this place it'll be the first time
in our lives we'll have to fend for
ourselves after we leave it'll be our
first time outside books about survival
and tips about how to use the
environment to our advantage would be a
literal lifesaver realizing now that
these toys mean the girl from earlier is
probably dead the tall kid angrily
confronts the main three about their
whereabouts knowing there's no point in
hiding the truth they tell him about
everything that happened on that day the
morning after emma tells norman about
her new plan to escape with all the kids
meanwhile the tall boy steals some
chemicals to help the operation at the
same time rey learns from mom that he
will be the next kid to be sent off the
tall lady finds the kids talking in the
forest and offers to team up knowing
about their plans to leave the orphanage
according to her if they escape then mom
will be fired and she'll take her place
in the orphanage to gain their trust she
tells them her history it turns out that
the tall lady was also an orphan that
managed to survive past the age limit
however if she leaves the surrounding
area a chip inside her will electrocute
and kill her from the inside now that
makes things more interesting now we
have to do is fry her insides and then
she dies if she betrays us that is
knowing that this lady's also been
through the same crazy [ __ ] that we have
makes her a little more trustworthy in
my opinion before it looked like a bit
of a trap but now we have some real
power on our side at this point we have
all the information we need we've got
books we've got a big powerful lady and
a bunch of kids who we can use as meat
shields if we want to i would propose an
idea since we now know one of the kids
can pick locks we could ambush mom and
night hold her hostage and use her as
leverage to leave the orphanage mom
seems like a valuable player within this
ecosystem of orphanages i would doubt
they would just let her die since the
tall lady wants her gone as well this is
a win-win situation she's got some dirt
on mom and we can use that as an excuse
for doing all of this crazy stuff if we
have the tall lady working alongside us
she can pretend that the kids are still
in the house while the demons over the
gates considering the fact that there
are endless trees and bushes and it
would be at night time i think the
chance of escaping would be pretty high
from what we know about these demons
which is not a lot they look pretty slow
we've been training relatively hard and
as kids we have tons of energy and it
looks like we could outrun them while
not entirely trusting of her the kids
and the lady make an agreement to work
together they meet in her room and
question her about the demon's
headquarters she tells them getting rid
of the tracker will set off an alarm and
the only way to do it is to cut their
micro chipped ear off well would you
look at that chopping your ear off
aren't i a genius while talking it's
obvious that they still don't completely
trust each other but continue to
cooperate meanwhile rey gets a new
camera as a gift from mom for his hard
work being the smart kids that they are
they purposely hide some secret info
about mom for the tall lady to find the
plan works as intended and she takes the
letter without knowing mom finds and
tells her that headquarters is sending
her to a different orphanage and that
she must leave today going to the gates
she meets the mysterious lady called
grandma who looks to be a rank above the
moms the tall lady tells grandma about
all the bad things mom's done in the
orphanage but it's all for nothing a
demon comes out of hiding and grandma
reveals to her that her and mom have
been working together this whole time by
her command the tall lady is savagely
killed by the demon monster meanwhile in
the house mom gathers rey and tells him
their partnership is over before he can
react she locks the door trapping him in
the room using the tracker mom looks for
emma and norman who are currently
investigating the massive wall luckily
for ray the tall kid finds him and
knocks the door down while this is going
on mom finds the others trying to escape
she catches them red handed and says
that they should just accept the fact
that their lives have been pretty good
so far and give up on leaving not
agreeing with her statement emma grabs
mom and drags her down while norman
grabs the ropes to scale the wall out of
rage mom savagely breaks emma's leg
before telling them that they need to
stay as some of them are the best meat
in the orphanage the two stop resisting
and norman is told that he's only got
one day left before he must leave the
orphanage you know what maybe she has a
point we don't actually know what our
circumstances were before this we are
orphans after all there's likely a
chance that all of us were homeless and
would have died without mom and the
demon's help so at this point i would
break out my puppy eyes and cry and
plead for her forgiveness and say that
mom is such a great figure and maybe we
can use our child like naivete and to
trick her into thinking that the escape
is over plus emma's leg is broken and as
far as that goes she's now a liability
for the group so i say we leave her and
we'll survive sorry emma i'm kidding i'm
kidding we all love emma mom does bring
up a good point though we need to think
about what happens once we get out for
all we know there could be dangerous
animals and killer insects crawling
around everywhere we need to mentally
and physically prepare ourselves for
what could be a long journey to
civilization assuming we're not stranded
in a post-apocalyptic landscape once
again emma's leg has just been broken
and the tall lady just got murdered so
we know mom is prepared to do the most
savage things to ensure we're sent off
to the demons not only that she's got to
be the most two-faced no-good nun lady
in the history of mankind raising up
kids just to send them to death i love
it in the next scene rey gives norman a
taser made by the parts from mom's gift
the three plan to use the taser to
disable his tracker this gives norman
time to hide in the forest until they
wait out the real escape day because of
this rey will likely be the next to go
in his place to avoid this he plans to
injure himself which will leave him
unable to be shipped off as they only
send the kids if they're fully healthy
before they go to bed rey decides to
tell the other two about his past it
turns out that he knew about the demons
all along as he does not experience
childhood amnesia this means that he
retained all of his memories dating back
to when he was a baby he reveals that
from a baby he was sent to the orphanage
and that beyond the gate is the demon
headquarters there are also five other
plants which have groups of kids just
like theirs this also means that he's
the only one who has any idea of the
outside world the next day norman goes
to the gate and manages to scale the
wall with the hidden ropes just barely
managing to climb it he gets his first
glimpse of the outside world sadly for
him there's only one more obstacle
there's a massive chasm covering the
outskirts of the wall as an extra layer
of protection while the plan was for him
to hide in the forest and wait out his
deadline he decides to come back to the
orphanage to the shock of absolutely
everyone well there's a massive chasm
which is a problem if i'm norman i'm
checking the area close to the gate
obviously the gate wouldn't lead to a
massive hole as well there's probably a
bridge or something that would easily
lead out to the forest or something
easier to traverse rey said that beyond
the gates is the demon headquarters but
from this massive forced landscape i
couldn't tell you if that's true or not
so i'm taking my chances either way
assuming there is it's now go time
tonight i'll be shipped off to certain
death i would wait till right after
sundown and assemble all the kids that
are fit enough climb the wall and make
our way down to the bridge we don't know
what's down there but there will be
limited visibility there's also one more
option we could zipline across this
chasm we have some pretty dang long
ropes and we could combine them to at
least see if we can make our way across
this chasm because i would rather not
take forever shaming our way down to
find out if this chasm was made by them
or not even with the massive gaping
chasm it's not all that bad this is the
first time we've seen the outside world
and it looks pretty much the same as
what we've always seen trees and bushes
this at least lets us know what we're
dealing with when we make our escape
later on the three kids gather round and
figure out that the area surrounding the
orphanage is shaped like a hexagon the
only other way out other than somehow
scaling the wall and jumping over the
massive hole is to go through the gate
but obviously if they go through the
gate most of them will probably get
killed and even alive by the demons to
the shock of emma and rey norman tells
him that he never planned to escape in
the first place he just wanted to help
them find out more information about
their surroundings he gives the taser
back and gets ready to leave the
orphanage saying his final farewells
emma with a broken leg tries to stop him
by breaking the tracker on his ear
before being pushed off it's too late
norman goes off with mom to certain
death however this time he's not killed
straight away norman gets taken away to
a side room by the gate with a disturbed
look on his face okay this is pretty bad
after all this hard work looks like
norman either gave up or never wanted to
escape at all before we can get too sad
we can think about this from a positive
perspective we now have two months until
another kid is gone that's a lot of time
and by the way we have a lot of kids for
what norman told us we now know it's
possible to get on top of the wall with
a little athletic ability first thing we
need to do is to keep our training up
kids who are a basic athletic level
naturally have higher endurance levels
than a lot of experienced endurance
athletes do due to fatigue resistant
muscles and the ability to recover
extremely fast because we're kids that
means whatever training we do is
increased tenfold once our fitness is
sorted it's time to escape i'd make sure
to bring enough food and water with us
to last a few days even though it'll
make it heavier and running will tires
out a lot faster the overall benefit of
having it versus not having it is
clearly better luckily we know that most
of the area is forced which means
there's water nearby forest are natural
filtration systems which collect and
produce water year-round we also need to
know how to make a fire luckily for us
all the materials we need are right next
to us by getting dry wood twigs bark
leaves and a flint we can make a fire
that'll last us through the night and
also we will use the fire to sanitize
the water killing any bacteria and bugs
that may be in the water knowing that
norman's probably dead the kids lose
confidence in the escape plan rey tells
the orcas that he's accepted his fate
and has given up after two months pass
no progress has been made and it looks
like he will be the next to go the night
before he's sent to death emma shocks
him by revealing she's never stopped
working on the escape plan glasses girl
and the tall kid have been working with
her without suspicion of mom due to
their depressive moods rey agrees that
they should initiate whatever operation
they're attempting but he won't be a
part of it he pours light a few on his
head in an attempt to light himself on
fire burning himself alive along with
the orphanage she manages to save him by
catching the lid match and convinces him
to go along with their plan now
preparing to initiate the plan rey cuts
his ear off with the microchip in it to
trick mom into thinking he's stuck in
the fire seeing his location still on
the house mom freaks out as he's one of
the highest quality supplies and
attempts to extinguish the fire but it's
too late she tries to access the hidden
room but the keyhole has been filled the
kids managed to make it to the massive
wall and use their ropes to scale it to
the top but rey is shocked to learn not
all the kids have made it mom grabs the
communicator before she watches the
house burn in flames standing outside a
little kid comes rushing to her arms it
turns out that the kids less than four
years old were left behind in a genius
play by emma she realized that the kids
can only be sent out after turning six
so she left them behind on purpose this
is a win-win situation the kids who are
too young would have probably had little
chance of surviving in the outside world
and the oldest kid still has about one
and a half years left until he or she's
sent off since she's also determined to
save them she plans to come back before
any of them have their sixth birthday
that's pretty badass it's also probably
the best plan you could have made in
this situation but i would disagree with
coming back we now know how big this
organization is with multiple orphanages
housing hundreds or even thousands of
kids we also know from the tall lady
they've been operating for a long time
decades or even longer this means they
have more power than we can even imagine
and i don't think it's possible for us
to get enough resources in less than two
years to save these kids well heartless
i would decide to leave them behind
because
it's terrible we already have enough on
our plate with saving ourselves i would
take the crappy option and get as far
away as possible from this crazy
orphanage before that though you know
what i would do i wouldn't use all of
the gasoline up on the house rather i
would set the whole farm on fire as well
the fire would likely kill mom and all
of the little ones but oh boo hoo crimea
river this woman has to be stopped while
the kids will die a pretty painful death
this will stop mom from raising more
helpless kids to be eaten the wildfire
would also serve as an element of
surprise showing headquarters that we
mean business and we are some kids that
are not to be messed with with the
younger kids safe mom calls up
headquarters and tells the demons that
there have been some escapees somehow
she manages to climb the wall in time
just before emma crosses the massive
hole with the makeshift zip line in an
act of kindness she removes the pulleys
and wishes the kids a safe journey in a
sudden flashback mom is shown to have
been raised in one of the orphanages
herself but instead of being killed she
was given the choice to become a mom and
begin her training while becoming a mom
she became a mom and gave birth to a
beautiful baby boy the kid she gave
birth to was rey while her child was
taken away as a baby she remembers rey
as he often humps the same song that she
herself used to with rey retaining his
memories as a baby he also knows that
mom is his mother failing in her mission
mom goes back to the younger kids and
tells them that the older ones have
successfully escaped the orphanage the
kids look onwards into the horizon as
they experience the morning sun of their
very first day
of freedom
but if you don't want to end up as a
tasty demon happy meal i'd suggest you
smash that like button comment down
below let us know what you like what you
didn't like be nice about it okay
and as always do it quick before mom
gets ya